and if anybody's looking for a doctor I
know one in the valley that'll see you
right away I mean Looking Back Now I
know that I probably was taken advantage
of in the doctor's office I ever tell
you this story nope we about the trauma
trauma dump no I I don't consider it
trauma because I I have laughed about it
many times that's a comic for you okay
so I get in I get in a car accident in
La when we were driving the Saturn I'm
driving in LA and I get T-boned my
back's a little [__] up my car is
[__] up to total and this woman is
not being cooperative and her you know
what I mean yeah and so I'm like all
right and so my lawyer was like hey just
go to a doctor because if we can get you
if I can talk to her lawyer and be like
hey we went and saw a doctor you want to
settle this up for just the car or
should we throw bod in there yeah cuz I
just wanted her to fix my [__] car
yeah 100%
so I go to the doctor and it's this dude
in the valley and I was a younger guy
and this is how I know man when people
say why didn't you speak up or why
didn't a lot of times when something
you're in the
moment you either assume somebody knows
more than you or why would I question
the doctor he's a doctor do you know
what I mean
yeah so I'm in there and he there like
you need a physical to you need to check
your back and all this stuff I was like
cool checks my back and he's like we're
gonna have to get just a couple X-rays
and I go okay and he goes and then I'm
just gonna need to check your prostate
and I was
like okay and I was like why he was like
just you know just need to need need to
be thorough and I was
like okay
and so this dude checks my prostate can
I tell you my honest attit dude sure was
like yep you got me you got me dude yeah
dude you got me what am I going to say
not the attitude you should have for a
dude willly sneakily sticking his finger
up your ass I was just like Yo dude you
got me you're not going to get fool me
once not twice you know what I'm saying
yeah I'm trying to think of a funny
funny name for him not the Hamburglar
but maybe like the Hemorrhoid burglar I
I dude he was the I don't know what he
was he was Dr [__]
jellyfinger but he he he and this is the
thing also like I didn't feel threatened
and honestly it was nice to know that my
prostate was healthy but at that young
you didn't need to get your prostate
checked right yeah probably I didn't no
not probably definitely cuz you don't
have to get your prostate check until
you turned like 40 right yeah yeah yeah
I didn't win my um legal battle I'm sure
the lawyer was like it why did he get a
prostate exam and they were like yeah I
don't we didn't tell them to wait wait
wait you you didn't you didn't win that
that case after she T-boned
you I
believe we didn't how is that
possible unless you were at fault no I I
got the car fixed did you have to pay
for it though no no no she she paid for
the Cary she P for the okay but I didn't
win what I wanted to win for her being
an [__] and then me getting
molested I don't mean to laugh by the
way everybody for those of you who got
molested
no that's not what we're aiming for I've
told you about the the Pilates teacher
who cut my nuts right you say hold on
cut with a tea or cup with a p cup no oh
dude let me deline no
no I was GNA say I knew she was crazy
like we were this is when I was working
at Chelsea Lately and uh Colona Sarah
Colona a good friend of mine she I was
like I want to try this Pilates she goes
yeah yeah yeah let's she goes you can go
to my te my instructor I'm like okay
and I was like I can't go to your
instructor uh because I'm going to be
taken to the gym next door but uh I'm
going to take it and I'll tell you how
it goes so like fifth lesson in and I
said to guy guy or girl teacher woman
okay I say to Sarah be this woman was so
knowledgeable dude everything I would do
she was like this is your whatever
muscle and attaches to this and this and
like she was so Technical and so
knowledgeable I was like this is the
most knowledgeable trainer I've ever had
she knows
everything so and there was this stretch
we would do where her hand one hand
would be on my leg pushing it and the
other hand was always kind of cupping
while you on your back yeah kind of
cupping my nuts yep not kind of cupping
my nuts cup of my nuts and um so I said
to Sarah in the office I go it's such a
great body full body work C cuz yeah I
go you know what weird I go you know
what stretch actually is the best for my
hamstring and she was like what I go
that one where you know she cups your
nuts and you don't have nuts but you
know she kind she probably has her hand
over your your vagina and she was like
what I go you know the cup your nuts and
she was like show me the show me show me
show me show and I showed it to her she
was like just so you know that's not a
thing nope and I was like what she was
like oh it might be a good hamstring
stretch but nobody the cup of the nuts
is not a thing she was like nobody's
supposed to cup your nuts and so I
remember I was like what she was like
yeah this is that's not a
you could go check any Pilates video you
want zero people cup the nuts zero nut
cupping so I remember going back to
her because I didn't want to it was such
a good workout I just didn't
want yeah I was
gonna I was okay with it when I thought
that was where she needed to base her
hand or I just don't question people who
I think know what they're doing you
should
so I go back to her and we start to get
in nut cuing position pause and I go PA
[__]
[Music]
pause [__] pause I'm in full nut
cup and uh she puts her one hand on my
leg and the other hand on your nuts
going went to cup the nuts and I go hey
she goes
yeah because I didn't want to lose her
as a teacher I didn't want to make her
feel
uncomfortable because honestly I didn't
take it as sexual and I didn't take it
as because they're professional and
you're thinking it's not just that dude
I wasn't in a
sexual there was nothing sexual but what
we were doing right and so I really
didn't even think twice about it I was
just like oh you know this is it it was
whatever it was like this is what
happens when you train sometimes someone
cups your nuts or whatever and so I
don't think that's the saying I said to
her yeah I said to her I go hey she goes
yeah I want you to know that I really
love this workout she said thank you and
I said I think you're incredibly
knowledgeable she said thank you and I
said you know and I love to I love this
stretch really I really tight hamstring
she goes you sure do I said but do you
have to cut my nuts she said 'I do not
and I said cool and that was it that's
hilarious was she just like doing it
until you said something no idea that
conversation didn't go any further than
that did nope you didn't go back another
time after that did you did I go back
and see her yeah yeah of course she was
a great instructor oh all right and it's
not like she was tickling my butthole
you know what I mean she was C the nuts
is pretty close to tickling the butthole
I feel like that's the next step she had
her hand over the entire area you know
so the hand was but but there was no
there was no butthole but was it purpose
like was it meant to be sexual by her I
can't the way she dismissed it and the
way we talked about it so
non-sexually I I think no the same time
yeah because she clearly performed the
stretch without the nut cup corre and
just as well but also like had she
offered it like Mage places offer Happy
Endings like if it's out on the table
for everything maybe more people will be
open to it you don't have to just
secretly cup all these dudes nuts I
don't think that she wants dudes coming
to Pilates hoping to get jerked off she
should stop at the gym she should stop
cupping dude's nuts yeah yeah yeah yeah
listen dude that's my only thing is like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm with you
but she was a great instructor if she's
listening which she isn't no she's not
because I don't I don't remember her
name either but she was a great
instructor D that was the same place
where this I got chewy a uh trainer and
we would train at the same time before
the show they on Chelsea Lately and
Che how would chew even train yo dude he
would do one rep of one set and then sit
on the bench and be like I'm tired why
are you torturing me it was amazing RP
chewy dog the bestard [__] love him
are you kidding me